ça vous à 2600 euros une fois des 1600
deux fois trois fois que je vais à
juillet 2006 adjé 2006 monsieur juillet
dernier dans une salle des ventes à
nantes
juliette jourdan anime les enchères mais
ce matin ce sont des lots un peu
particulier des colis tous perdus par la
poste
[Musique]
parmi les bonnes affaires du jour ce
robot de cuisine remporté à un tiers de
son prix en magasin maurice et yvette
n'en reviennent pas jean moulin
[Musique]
ici il ya même des commerçants qui en
profitent pour approvisionner leurs
boutiques quincaillerie chaussures ou
encore dvd certaines marchandises sont
vendues par container au mètre cube
c'est bienvenue à jamie monsieur yves st
maurice qui viennent ici pour la
première fois sont étonnés d'apprendre
l'origine de ces marchandises qu'on est
surpris du vin les quantités c'est
vraiment la poste les colis et qui n'ont
jamais directement
c'est impensable voici une fois par an
ou deux fois par mois
ça vous étonne oui assez d'ouvrir la
quantité des codie égarés et ce n'est
que la partie visible de l'iceberg
toujours plus d'incidents ce serait le
prix de livraison toujours plus rapide
[Musique]
avec internet nous sommes toujours plus
nombreux à faire des courses en ligne
sur des sites marchands
ces pratiques surtout depuis que les
paiements à distance ont été sécurisés
[Musique]
mais la chaîne à son maillon faible les
livraisons à domicile voilà l'impact
qu'on avait sur la plonge donc la
planche là elle est morte jusqu'à un
colis sur quatre arriverait endommagé en
retard ou n'arriverait même jamais en
particulier pendant les fêtes de fin
d'année livré en temps et en heure un
impératif pour ceux qui se partagent ce
marché juteux de plusieurs milliards
d'euros
et dans cette course infernale tous les
coups sont permis
nous percevrons les secrets de réussite
de leaders comme amazon
[Musique]
je ne fais pas ta gueule
à quel transporteur font-ils appel et
pourquoi les sous traitants en bout de
chaîne sont-ils débordé je vais semi à
sa place et voilà j'ai à peu près bonne
demi heure de retard
bonhomme urbain
combien coûte réellement une livraison à
domicile enquête dans les coulisses
méconnu d'un secteur en plein essor
[Musique]
pour comprendre le mécanisme
nous commençons par faire un achat sur
internet une paire de chaussures il est
9 heures nous validons la transaction le
site nous garantit une livraison dès le
lendemain avant midi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'étape suivante a lieu dans l'entrepôt
du site marchand c'est la préparation du
colis est le plus performant en la
matière cette amazone
le leader mondial du e-commerce ici les
colis sont prêts à être expédiés deux
heures à peine après la commande un
temps record pour ce site marchand connu
pour être aussi imbattable sur la
rapidité que sur les tarifs de ses
livraisons
cela fait deux ans que ce mastodonte
américain est devenu lé enseignes
préférées des français
lui c'est thierry van treeck il est
belge souriant et les managers
on se prépare pour eux de nos vallées de
notre but c'est vraiment garantir que
tous les tous les cadeaux sont à livrer
en temps et en heure en dessous en
dessous du sapin donc ça c'est vraiment
le lagon priorité pour l'instant une
grosse préparation en prévision
l'année dernière pour noël amazon a
réussi à envoyer jusqu'à 760 1000
articles en une seule journée soit
départ camion toutes les sept minutes
[Musique]
quels sont les ingrédients de cette
recette miracle pour nous l'expliqué
thierry nous oriente vers l'une de ses
collègues
samia
samia c'est un peu l'employé modèle
[Musique]
sous l'oeil attentif de son manager et
du responsable de la communication
la jeune femme nous fait une
démonstration de préparation de colis
pour une productivité optimale
amazon équipe tous ses employés d'une
machine à scanner
c'est aussi plus loin dans les allées
pas d'erreur possible pour samia qui
sait exactement où chercher les articles
sans jamais perdre de temps mais dès
qu'on aborde avec elle la question du
rythme de travail
au fait comment tu commandes par jour
par des micros commandes
c'est dire qu'on peut commander un
article recommandé vincent est
l'objectif de ce matin parce que c'était
belgique je crois que je vais pas vous
le dire
les objectifs ont niveau n'y est pas
nos questions dérangent management
faut quand même
oui il faut aller il faut il faut aller
vite
il faut surtout aller à une cadence
raisonnable si vous regardez bien vous
ne verrez pas les personnes stressées 1
regardez autour de vous il n'ya pas
[Musique]
deux conditions de ce prêt tout en tout
cas s'il en avait on se battrait pour ne
pas qu'ils en amazone refusera de nous
en dire plus sur les conditions de
travail dans l'entreprise
nous décidons alors d'infiltrer l'un de
leurs entrepôts pour la première fois
nous parvenons à introduire une caméra
cachée
malgré d'importants dispositifs de
sécurité car pour limiter les vols les
salariés sont contrôlés systématiquement
dans l'entrepôt impossible de garder sur
soi un téléphone portable ou tout autres
effets personnels recrutés en tant
qu'intérimaire nous rejoignons l'équipe
du week-end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
les quotas qu'exige ce manager c'est de
faire 260 colis par heure pour cela nous
parcourons 30 km par jour dans cet
entrepôt grand comme dix terrains de
football au détour d'une allée nous
tentons d'aborder une autre intérimaire
[Musique]
voici comment ici c'est par la personne
et à droite
exor par les grands titres dont
notamment à la roja
il faut un porte parole
ça c'est le fameux scanne un mouchard
qui permet de suivre le moindre
déplacement des employés un moyen de
contrôler redoutable
le salon que la demi finale
et ça on
page que je veux comme un pervers nous
prouver
la feinte de corps se rendit à la fin
mon cabaret
ccoo qui n'ont pas pour moi c'est
inférieur club de canal
toutes ces informations permettent de
calculer la productivité de chaque
travailleur au colis près
et pour les moins bons éléments le
couperet peut vite tomber
tyson
à la fin de leur contrat
entre adar ii
seuls les plus performants voient leur
contrat renouvelé dans cet entrepôt
plus de deux tiers des salariés ont été
embauchés en tant qu'intérimaire des
contrats précaires et une cadence
parfois difficile à tenir
[Musique]
[Rires]
le cinquième jour de notre infiltration
une jeune femme s'écroule devant nous
une chef d'equipe tente alors de la
calmer emmené à l'infirmerie
elle y restera quelques heures nous la
retrouvons en fin de journée
tu m'envoies à droite à gauche à droite
à gauche toute
amazon une entreprise sous le feu de la
critique contreverse sur son rythme de
travail intense mais aussi sur les aides
publiques que l'entreprise a touché pour
son implantation dans les régions en
crise et surtout polémique sur sa
domiciliation fiscale au luxembourg sur
ce dernier point le trésor public
réclame 200 millions d'euros à amazon
pour sa défense le géant américain
répond que ce contentieux fiscal est
actuellement à l'étude et qu'il faut
donc attendre la décision finale et
notre paire de chaussure alors nous les
avions acheté à 9 heures il est 11
heures
le colis est prêt c'est maintenant que
le site marchand fait appel aux services
d'un transporteur pour la livraison
[Musique]
eli a l'embarras du choix la poste
leader historique avec ses colissimo sa
filiale chronopost
mais aussi ses concurrents comme tnt
fedex dhl ou ups tous capables de livrer
en moins de 24 heures
à travers le monde pour notre colis
c'était un thé qui s'en chargent
direction son centre de tri le plus
proche
c'est ici que tous les colis collectés
chez des sites marchands des environs
sont conduits et ils sont alors trier
pour repartir en camion vers leur
destination en france un grand nombre de
centres de tri sont de taille moyenne
comme celui ci mais pour faire face aux
défis du commerce mondial certains
transporteurs se sont équipés de centres
de tri gigantesque
pas moins de 37 avions des charges et
chaque soir sur le tarmac une superficie
de près de cent mille mètres carrés et
30 kilomètres de tapis roulant nous
sommes à cologne en allemagne chez ubs
chaque jour ce leader mondial distribuer
plus de 16 millions de colis et pour
livrer tous ses paquets parfois à
l'autre bout de la planète dès le
lendemain matin c'est la nuit qps fait
tourner ses plus gros centres de tri
[Musique]
cet homme mon gilet jaune c'est à hugo
becker chargé d'accueillir les visiteurs
au pied de son plus grand avion cargo il
ne perd pas une minute pour nous montrer
le soin qu'il apporte à ces colis qui
viennent tout juste d'atterrir
il n'y a que le pilote et le copilote à
l'intérieur les plus importants de nos
passagers dans un avion comme celui ci
ce sont nos colis ou plutôt les colis de
nos clients
aucun passager dans ce long courrier
transformée en énorme soute à bagages
ainsi configurer cet avion peut
transporter jusqu'à 110 8 tonnes de
marchandises
[Musique]
et pour orchestrer ce ballet
ininterrompu de colis direction la salle
des contrôles
on peut y aller
et
nous sommes au coeur du système ces
hommes gèrent simultanément les flux
d'avion de camions et de colis mais
qu'est ce qui se passe est une surcharge
[Musique]
la tension est palpable
soudainement ils font face à un pic
d'activité qui n'était pas prévu
on peut leur poser quelques questions
non on ne peut pas ils sont trop occupés
aiko nour dirige alors vers la zone de
déchargement des colis
à peine débarqué dans le centre de tri
les paquets sont triés ici en fonction
de leur taille petit standard ou hors
norme
puis grâce aux scans de leur étiquette
ils sont regroupés en fonction de leur
destination
[Musique]
là-bas le scanner va trouver quelle est
la destination du colis une fois que
c'est fait 25 secondes plus tard il part
pour paris
il reste donc encore 25 secondes sur ce
tapis roulant avant qu'il n'aille
rejoindre tous les autres colis pour par
kaka et hop 25 secondes plus tard le
colis tu tombes dans le bon sac une
synchronisation au millimètre qui permet
de trier 110 mille colis par heure
l'année prochaine
ubs espère doubler ce rythme pas de quoi
effrayer highco pour qui tout est sous
contrôle
toutes les zones sont vérifiés par un
employé on s'assure donc qu'aucun colis
ne soient laissées dans les bâtiments
même si les bâtiments sont immenses
même si c'est immense tout est sous
contrôle
officiellement la belle mécanique ne se
grippe donc jamais pourtant d'après un
sondage récent quel que soit le
transporteur concerné des livraisons
sont une source de stress pour plus d'un
consommateur sur deux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les problèmes ne sont pas rares
en tout cas pour bastien lui a connu
plusieurs mésaventures avec différents
transporteurs bastien vie du kitesurf
[Musique]
papa le métier dock avec surfer c'est
comme ça tous les jours c'est comme ça
tous les jours
mais ya pas que ça non plus il ya toute
la partie revente matériel qui va
financer une bonne partie de notre
budget compétition et voyages comme ses
sponsors lui fournissent du matériel
gratuitement il en revend régulièrement
sur un site de petites annonces entre
particuliers
de quoi arrondir ses fins de mois
du moins quand les colis arrive à bon
port alors le jeu soucis avec le mât
talent de kite c'est souvent quelque
chose passer le matin c'est pas souvent
c'est du matériel qui est cher et on se
pose toujours la question quand on
envoie ce matériel est ce qu'il va bien
arriver au bout et ce qui va arriver en
état on parle de sommes d'argent qui
sont quand même assez conséquente
puis le problème récurrent c'est la
casse on a beau emballé sur remballer le
matériel
il m'est arrivé voilà d'avoir du
matériel cassé à l'arrivée donc c'est
jamais très agréable
récemment bastien a envoyé une planche
par la poste à un particulier qui
habitent à peine à 30 kilomètres de chez
lui
manifestement il aurait mieux fait de
faire le trajet lui même donc voilà la
planche la planche en question la plante
qui a été envoyé dans qu'avec double
épaisseur de cartons il ya du plastique
à l'intérieur les extrémités étaient
protégés par du plastique le carton la
plante ne dépassez pas le colis
initialement il était comme ça
et en fait qui a alarmé le l'acheteur
c'est que bâtit les allées rectal colis
il a trouvé le polycom ça et cet
enfoncement le carton déjà un petit peu
déchiqueté donc qui s'est dit oulala il
ya souci et en ouvrant le carton la
hauteur de l'impact sur le carton voit
l'impact qu'on avait sur la planche donc
la planche là elle est morte
l'acheteur a refusé le colis bastien qui
avaient souscrit une assurance contre la
casse pensait pouvoir facilement se
faire rembourser
mais il rencontre un deuxième problème
pour que je puisse être indemnisé pour
que l'assurance que j'avais prise sur ce
colis fonctionne il fallait que je
puisse constater moi aussi le
l'avarice hurle sur le colis or le colis
a été déposé voilà en mon absence et
donc j'ai pas pu constater quoi que ce
soit je me suis retrouvé devant le fait
accompli pour faire valoir ses droits
bastien décide de se rendre à son bureau
de poste nous le suivrons en caméra
cachée
et puis en même temps pendant que je
vais faire ça il a aussi par rapport à
une planche que j'ai envoyée il ya
certes content parce que ça
m'inquiéterait montpellier qui arrive
est cassé à montpellier sa vie est une
assurance et c'était 1 tommy haas rêve
c'était une planche de valeur c'est une
planche qui va les 800 euros vous placez
un voyant lui ont recommandé qu il reste
6 2 canaux hertz maxime bastien
pensaient être à l'abri mais après
quelques minutes
le diagnostic tombe en clair le livreur
enregistré le colis comme non réclamés
par le client or ils devaient
l'enregistrer comme un colis refusé il
n'y a donc aucune trace de refus ni de
la part du destinataire ni de la part de
bastia
mauvaise volonté ou pas du livreur à
cause de ses erreurs cumulées
bastien aura du mal à prouver que la
planche était cassée au moment de la
livraison
son seul recours désormais attendre que
la poste mène une enquête interne avec
la poste ou n'importe quel autre
transporteur il vaut mieux être prudent
en cas de coliques assez pour connaître
les bons réflexes à adopter
nous sommes allés rencontrer michel
bernard da juriste dans une association
de consommateurs
si le paquet et endommagé qu'en plus
c'est un bien de valeur donc ça peut
être un paquet qui semble avoir été
ouverts ça peut être un paquet ou qu'à
un coin écrasé renvoyé tout ce qui va
être un petit peu suspect comme ça un
peuplier des choses comme ça il faut
savoir tout de suite se dire j'ai le
droit
la loi est comme ça de prendre le temps
d'examiner le paquet d'ouvrir le colis
avant d'accepter le bien 1
le mieux est de refuser le colis en
disant voilà j'ai un doute sur le fait
que le bien puisqu'au mentir fonctionner
correctement
si le colis a été acheté à un
professionnel sur internet pas de
panique
le site marchand est dans l'obligation
d'en renvoyer un nouveau en revanche
dans le cas d'un envoi entre
particuliers les choses peuvent assez
vite se compliquer en confrontant son
expérience avec d'autres kitesurfeurs
bastien s'est rendu compte qu'il
existait des situations bien pires que
la sienne à cette personne me raconte
que
la mise en vente sont elles sur un site
de vente en ligne voilà la même démarche
que moi sauf que pour cette personne les
choses ont tourné manière différente
officiellement le paquet aurait été
détruit par accident oui mais voilà
quelques semaines plus tard ce
consommateur découvre que son aile de
kite et finalement vendue aux enchères
par la poste elle même quand je vois ça
je me dis mais ça veut dire que la
garantie contre lecompte donne elle vaut
rien pour lé ton matériel appartement où
tu l'envoies tu prend un énorme risque
quoi mais qui décide d'envoyer les colis
à des ventes aux enchères
pourquoi malgré des réclamations et même
des garanties les colis perdus ne sont
ils pas remis à leurs propriétaires
pour en savoir plus nous nous sommes
rendus à libourne près de bordeaux c'est
ici que tous les colis perdus de la
poste à terry chaque année un centre
unique qui n'existe qu'à la poste
pascal fontaine et chef d'equipe lui et
ses collègues sont chargés d'ouvrir les
colis égarés
[Musique]
on va quelques colis et on va voir si on
trouve une adresse ou pas mais ce matin
ça commence mal
là il n'ya pas d'adressent d'un contenu
c'est du papier prospectus on encore
rien à faire donc on va
voilà lui à l'abattement
marche encore très souvent ces colis
n'ont pas trouvé leurs destinataires car
l'étiquette avec leur adresse s'est
détaché il est signé par ya pas
l'adresse extérieure mais heureusement
ce colis issus du commerce sur internet
contient une facture voilà les lie à
leur s donc on va le renvoyer
on a renvoyé ce colis ce qui est
l'adresse du client
je suis là héros part aujourd'hui mieux
vaut donc toujours prendre la précaution
de glisser une adresse à l'intérieur de
ces colis
sinon les marchandises risque de finir
aux enchères comme cette bouteille de
rhum même deux ya des embouteillages à
l'intérieur qui viennent
de la martinique qui sont des produits
qu'on va pouvoir destinés à la vente en
fait voilà en partant d'ici en fait on
va avoir plein de petits objets qui sont
destinés à la vente
qu'on appelle ici dans le service la
petite vente en fait
a contrario avec la grosse vente vous
voyez là-bas le container où on met
plutôt les gros objets destinés à la
vente
là les petits objets on les met ici on a
déjoué on a tout ce qui est mercerie on
a de la quincaillerie en plein de trucs
différents de l'horlogerie avec des
montres en début de semaine et on a fait
pas mal de nettoyage vendredi
du coup c'est vide mais très souvent
c'est quand même vachement archi-plein
voilà tous ces objets trouvés
aujourd'hui partiront très rapidement
aux enchères soit à nantes deux fois par
mois soit à lyon pourtant le client a
normalement trois mois pour réclamer son
colis perdus
alors pourquoi ces conditions générales
de vente ne sont elles pas respecté nous
avons demandé des explications à
véronique teulières la directrice du
site de libourne
[Musique]
le client globalement il a trois mois
pour réclamer son colis après il y a
je dirais une organisation interne poste
qui nous appartient dans cette
organisation
nous décidons arbitrairement que des
biens courants potentiellement jamais
réclamés seront mis en vente plus
rapidement et que nous portons nos
efforts et les ressources que nous
affectons à cette activité gratuite pour
les clients à des biens qui
potentiellement ont de la valeur
seuls les objets de valeur sont stockées
pendant trois mois dans l'attende une
réclamation
mais quand on la poste par objets de
valeur pascal fontaine nous ouvre son
coffre fort
[Musique]
c'est voilà au type d'objets qu'on peut
trouver un vieux casque un de l'armée
ah oui d'époque je voulais faire la
grande vadrouille c'est parfait les clés
usb d'occasion pas les neufs d'occasion
si jamais il ya un an qui est écrit
dessus ça peut ça peut ça peut marcher
des objets d'une valeur toute relative
des clés usb d'occasion des jouets
rouillés ou encore des raquettes démodé
en bref des vieilleries qui rapporteront
sans doute très peu aux enchères ça ce
type d'objet
quels sont les bénéfices de ces ventes
aux enchères nous ne le saurons pas mais
une certitude
trois cent mille colis arrivent chaque
année à libourne un chiffre
impressionnant
pourtant après la poste cela
représenterait moins d'un colis sur 1000
mais qu'en est il pour les autres
transporteurs combien de rater
déplore-t-il nous avons tenté de les
joindre
combien ce que vous avez de colis qui
arrivent en retard ou qu'ils n'arrivent
jamais ou qui arrivent cassé chaque
année y a pas de statistiques
silence radio
aucune entreprise n'acceptera de nous
dévoiler ses chiffres
d'après nos informations il y aurait
environ 1% de colis perdus sur
l'ensemble du secteur pour les retards
les chiffres grimperait jusqu'à 25% chez
des plus mauvais élèves
si les entreprises communiquent peu
c'est aussi parce que derrière ces
retards et ses pertes
il y a de plus en plus de vols
[Musique]
à
6h ce matin plusieurs individus entre 6
et 9 font irruption en hurlant dans ce
centre de tri et n'hésitant pas à
braquer le personnel est tombé nez à nez
avec un bras caire il ya un marché rien
il va
il m'a fait reculer actuelle le pistolet
il savait qu'il fallait aller vite et
puis il savait quoi faire et où aller en
fait mal tout ce qui est de valeur en
fait à tout ce qui est sensiblement dit
chez nous les écouler sensible braquage
d'entrepôts braquage de camions
agression deux livreurs
le secteur ne compte plus les incidents
violents les modes opératoires sont
similaires aux attaques de banques ou de
bijouterie des individus cagoulés
équipés de pinces monseigneur comme sur
cette vidéo surveillance il opère en
moins de dix minutes et n'hésite pas à
agresser des employés leur cible des
produits de valeur comme des smartphones
les cosmétiques ou encore des bijoux un
transporteur a accepté de nous montrer
comment il luttait contre ces nouvelles
menaces
nous avons rencontré son directeur de
sûreté
arnaud corade chez lui les centres de
tri sont des forteresses
ça commence par quoi la sécurité alors
la sécurité ça commence d'abord par
l'extérieur de l'entrepôt si je veux
protéger mon entrepôt à l'intérieur il
faut d'abord que je commence en amont à
l'extérieur alors par se passe cette
barrière que vous voyez là ce poteau
c'est une barrière infrarouge
j'ai plein de photos qui communique tout
autour qui font tout le tour du bâtiment
et communiquent entre eux et quand le
site est fermé bien s'il fait chaud et
rompus si une personne il ya un passé eh
bien ça déclenche des alarmes pomper
limite rigide protégée en amont une
barrière infrarouge des caméras de
vidéosurveillance mais pas seulement
cet ancien légionnaire va jusqu'à faire
appel à des techniques militaires sur
certaines de nos agences
on met en place une contre surveillance
c'est à dire que les malfaiteurs ont
l'habitude de grenouilles et autour de
nos sites pour épier un peu les faits et
gestes de des camions voir où les
camions vont charger les charges et donc
on a recours à des sociétés de sécurité
privées qui font des patrouilles à pied
ou en véhicule de manière très discrète
pour d'abord m les malfaiteurs en
insécurité parce qu'ils le sentent et ça
permet bien souvent de détecter des vols
les braquages en amont attaques
extérieures mais aussi intérieures car
ce sont parfois les salariés eux-mêmes
qui volent des colis et leurs techniques
sont dignes des meilleurs pickpockets
seul un regard averti peu les déjouer
tenez voilà c'est cet endroit
précisément jeunes autres voiliers avec
le pied on voit donc la personne qui
place le pli sous un brocoli et ensuite
le cache le dissimule sous la chaîne
pour que son complice le récupère par la
suite voilà ça dure très dure à peine
une seconde pour mettre fin à ces
pratiques
la société s'est équipée d'un système de
vidéosurveillance ultra sophistiqué
[Musique]
nécessité aujourd'hui dans le métier du
transport de colis
car
vous imaginez bien que toutes ces colis
à suscite la convoitise et en fait
toutes les chaînes sont couvertes sur
toute la longueur
et c'est ce qui permet en fait de suivre
l'avis d'un colis de son entrée dans le
dépôt jusqu'à sa sortie 326 caméra
reliée à un système informatique
en entrant le numéro d'un colis arnaud
corade pour retrouver son trajet de a à
z dans le centre de tri
je dois être sont les recherches pouvoir
garder mathieu vous avez consulté là les
historiques des coûts liés aux charges
de traces sur les 33,7 premier call it
votre numéro de colis ici et là j'ai la
correspondance automatique du logiciel
par rapport à ceux gouly donc le colis
car chercher sur le vent au tunnel voilà
c'est une autre prise du tunnel on voit
bien ici qu'il est poussé dans cette
goulotte et donc la cij avance un petit
peu voilà on voit bien mon pneu qui
arrive dans ma culotte
j'ai le numéro de caisse c'est une
caisse que sur le camion qui est censé
aller dans le 94
ici on a la date de chargement dont + 4
septembre on a également leur de
chargement où tout va bien la caisse
tout âge 42 41
ce système inédit de suivi de colis a
coûté 6 millions d'euros mais pour le
transporter le bilan est largement
positif
voilà dans 94 c'est bon
en fait ce système a mis un coup d'arrêt
je dirais aux vols en interne un par ces
vols sont commis par les salariés en
interne et du coup est bien forcé main
ces vols mécaniquement se sont reportés
sur le transport si arnaud corade
protège efficacement ses bâtiments
difficile d'en faire autant avec les
camions une fois sortie des centres de
tri
[Musique]
à une heure du matin notre colis est
enfin trier direction sa destination
finale
il a encore plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres à parcourir
d'après les dernières statistiques
chaque jour en france plus de 80000
euros de marchandise s'évaporent dans la
nature
et c'est donc sur la route qu'il est le
plus vulnérable
parviendra-t-il à échapper aux bandits
de grand chemin
face aux attaques de camions toujours
plus nombreuses les sociétés
d'autoroutes n'ont pas eu d'autre choix
que de créer des aires de repos sécurisé
nous sommes près de valenciennes dans la
commune ça ne s'invente pas de la
sentinelle prix d'une nuit 23 euros ça
peut paraître un peu cher mais ça a ses
avantages
hugues routier belge de 47 ans on est
convaincu savez le voleur n'est jamais
seul
c'est des bandes organisées qui savent
exactement ce qu'ils vont chercher et où
ils vont chercher pour une guérison
complète sans aucun un coup de couteau
20 coups de barre de fer dans la tête
vous rester là pendant trois heures
c'est pas un problème pour eux ils
prennent le camion ils s'en vont où ils
prennent la marchandise et pour
comprendre leur technique
hugues tient à nous montrer l'état de la
bâche de son camion
koné voire
voyez ça c'est des coups de couteau qui
a eu hier sas a été coupée hier ou
avant-hier on met une banque comme ça et
puis le week-end c'est réparé ça fait
une coupure de gamins celle là elle est
droite
il doit prendre ses deux mains pour
écarter tandis que là en coupant comme
ça et poussent ils voient tous les
matins ça sont pas des amateurs
ça c'est les amateurs ça c'est des
petits trucs ça c'était un petit gamin
voyez la hauteur la hauteur de l'homme
qui a coupé
moi je peux vous dire c'est un enfant
ici c'est un gars comme moi un mec 82
ici je suis certain que demain matin je
vais faire mon tour il y aura rien cette
nuit hugues comme des dizaines d'autres
chauffeurs dormira sur ses deux oreilles
[Musique]
bonne nuit sans voix une aubaine pour la
société qui gère l'air de repos
[Musique]
oh
hier on a fait 66 français 130 étrangers
les choristes des cours mais si vous
avez du succès oui de plus en plus il ya
des parades de la ligne ça fait
exception voilà on est pas loin
pas loin de la saturation pour fin
d'année c'est oui je pense que descendre
ça va ça va donner aussi l'avant lui
fait d'ici l'an prochain 30 places
supplémentaires seront aménagés en plus
des 184 existantes en france on compte
désormais 11 parking de ce type sur les
principaux axes routiers et notre colis
alors ouf
le chargement du camion n'a pas été
détournés pendant le trajet
mais notre cody n'est pas tirés
d'affaires pour autant pour sa dernière
étape
ils passent dans la camionnette du
livreur plus que 15 km mais attention
c'est sur ce dernier trajet que les
problèmes ont tendance à s'accumuler en
particulier quand les colis soit disant
livré n'arrive jamais en cette fin de
journée à montpellier
c'est l'une des problématiques abordées
lors d'une réunion de consommateurs
bonsoir tout le monde bienvenue c'est
michel bernard da la juriste de
l'association clcv qui anime ce café
conso bon on commence quand même on y va
alors quand on parle de noël je pense
qu'il ya des éléments aussi comme ça il
ya des fois des dates butoir des dates
d'échéance des événements importants
peut-être est-ce qu'il y en a qui se
sont trouvés en difficulté en
commandants mawlawi à noël il ya qu il
ya déjà deux trois ans quand j'ai
commandé pour les enfants des disques
durs et autres abats mon cadeau n'est
jamais arrivé donc pour eux c'était
arrivé poids final quoi c'est arrivé
donc ça allait livrer à quelqu'un mais à
qui elle est rose art nature ou par un
non sens signature donc en fait je n'ai
jamais mon colis enfin kaka est un beau
cadeau
malgré ses déboires cette consommatrice
a renoncé à entreprendre des démarches
car le site marchand et le transporteur
se sont renvoyés la balle un cas
classique
la loi est claire par internet c'est le
vendeur qui est responsable
donc le consommateur il devrait même pas
être confronté à ce style de renvoi de
responsabilité entre le transporteur
mandaté par le vendeur c'est le vendeur
l'interlocuteur et en cas de collines
ont reçu la loi et du côté du
consommateur
si le bien n'a pas été livré à compter
de la date prévue de livraison le
consommateur dans les 60 jours peut
demander l'annulation de la vente aux
professionnels et il sera remboursé ça
dans un délai de 30 jours maximum
bonne nouvelle donc mais comment
expliquer qu'il y ait autant de
problèmes en fin de course
[Musique]
c'est peut-être parce que les livraisons
à domicile ne sont pas faites par les
transporteurs eux-mêmes mais par leurs
sous traitants
et qui dit sous traitants dis souvent
aux conditions de travail au rabais
un livreur a accepté de nous en parler
il est salarié d'un sous-traitant de
chronopost
c'est au petit matin que nous le
retrouvons chez lui avant le début de sa
tournée
5h15 je m'apprête à aller au dépôt tous
les jours du lundi au samedi
des plus difficiles
le réveil n'effaçait pas évident c'est
que mon travail en six jours sur sept on
n'a pas beaucoup de repos donc allant à
la langue c'est un peu difficile
en témoignant ce salarié risque de
perdre son emploi pour préserver son
anonymat nous l'appellerons donc jérôme
s'il commence si tôt c'est parce que
c'est à lui de préparer les colis avant
de partir en tournée avant chronopost
employés des manutentionnaires pour
cette tâche
mais depuis six ans le transporteur
exige de ses sous-traitants de s'en
charger
quasiment gratuitement après deux heures
de tri jérôme peut enfin commencer à
s'occuper de ses premiers clients
chaque jour il doit livrer 200 colis
mais non inscrits et colis ne cherche
pas on pourrait penser que la tournée de
jérôme est organisée à l'avance en
fonction de l'itinéraire le plus court
possible mais en réalité c'est loin
d'être le cas pour certains cody jérôme
à des impératifs de livraison avant 9
heures avant 10 heures ou avant 13
heures de quoi compliquer son parcours
et ce n'est que le début et j'avais
récupéré aussi
et au ministre est permis ou pas oh non
non à midi c'est aller retour imprévu va
surcharger son planning horaire et non
j'ai à peu près bonne demi heure de
retard
bonhomme est en retard malgré sa bonne
volonté
jérôme n'arrête pas de perdre du temps
embouteillage stationnement compliqué
colis lourds et difficiles à porter à
cause de ces obstacles
c'est la course contre la mort les sages
et les politiques qui bascule
c'était la pagaille de dans l'aventuré
je cherche
mais le pire pour lui ce sont les
adresses introuvable donc là le 690
c'est tout seul
le petit chemin donc il ya à peu près
deux maisons alors quand il peut alléger
sa charge de travail
jérôme le fait sans hésiter quitte à
faire quelques entorses au règlement
je vais signer donc d'après ses accès
des accords avec les clients ça arrange
tout le monde que ce mois sacré show biz
vu lol représenter demain et aux clients
il a tout de suite fait je n'ai pas ce
[Applaudissements]
fait toujours si on ne sont pas de
courir quand même ce serait dommage
voilà ce que fait jérôme c'est une
usurpation de signature un délit
passible de 45000 euros d'amendé en cas
de contestation du client jérôme risque
de perdre son emploi
mais sa préoccupation du moment c'est de
réussir à tout livrer à temps le soir
il n'y a pas de pause si j'ai dix
minutes pour - le midi c'est pas
fréquent et c'est maxime que je puisse
avoir
parti de chez lui à 5h15 du matin
jérôme ne rentrera à la maison qu'à
18h30
le jeune homme finit par se confier
on s'est constamment
alors celui dans le patron
mais bon
accablant vous envie de tout lâcher on
imitons d'énervement malheureusement
j'ai tu les connais par terre on a tout
eu des collègues en ema aimable jeu
payer 35 heures par semaine ils
travaillent parfois jusqu'à deux fois
plus six jours sur sept
ces heures supplémentaires ne sont
quasiment jamais payé rapporté au taux
horaire ils gagnent l'équivalent du
salaire moyen bulgare soit 4 euros 50 de
l'heure dans ces conditions impossible
de livrer à domicile de façon optimale
pour contourner ce problème
les consommateurs peuvent désormais
choisir de se faire livrer en magasin
mais est ce vraiment la solution à paris
marine tient une boutique de vêtements
pour enfants et depuis un an maintenant
son magasin est aussi un point relais
c'est mon livreur vous allez bien
marine apprécie beaucoup son livreur
mais nettement moins les colis qui lui
apporte chaque jour une centaine de
colis à trier chaque jour des dizaines
de coups de ville pour renseigner les
clients impatients pas encore les mêmes
les erreurs du livreur
c'est à elle de les gérer l'adresse
d'une personne chez elle directement
souvent tous les jours pour cette
commerçante
ce système de remise de colis est donc
plutôt contraignant et parfois pour le
consommateur les avantages sont loin
d'être évident ces braconniers
parce que lis ça fait plus de dix jours
que je l'attend donc comme c'est un
cadeau pour un anniversaire
il arrive trop tard
et il savait pourtant elle arrive si
tard non mais je n'ai aucune explication
donc je suis passé trois fois la
boutique heureusement qu'elle n'est pas
trop loin de chez moi
coli en retard et parfois cody
impossible à récupérer quand les
commerçants partent en vacances les
transporteurs ne préviennent pas
systématiquement les clients des colis
donc quelqu'un qui se fait livrer on
était il risque de pas avoir son colis
avant un mois ou deux semaines enfin
suivant le temps de fermeture d'un
magasin et ceux dont les clients sont
loin de se douter c'est le montant de la
rémunération de marine pour ses collines
donc
pour un mois pour 180 en colis j'ai
gagné 51 euros et 85 centièmes qui fait
ça me fait deux euros par vaux avec les
relais en magasin les commerçants sont
donc encore moins payés que les livreurs
résultat moins d'un an après avoir tenté
l'expérience
marine a décidé d'arrêter son contrat
avec mondial relay
jérôme lui travaille désormais pour un
autre sous traitant car son ancien
patron a dû mettre la clé sous la porte
chez amazon
le contrat de la jeune intérimaire qui a
fait un malaise n'a pas été renouvelé
[Musique]
bastien le kitesurfeur a enfin été
remboursés pour sa planche cassé au bout
de quatre mois et demi quand un autre
colis nous l'avons bien reçu le
lendemain matin
je me sens
ça
[Musique]
depuis sa sortie de l'entrepôt à
montélimar il aura parcouru 600
kilomètres jusqu'à paris en passant par
deux centres de tri avant d'arriver dans
le dépôt parisien au total il a transité
entre les mains de 11 personnes
différentes
il nous a bien été livrés sans retard et
sans dommage
tout le monde ne pourra pas en dire
autant à la veille des fêtes
car selon nos informations cette année
les transporteurs seront confrontés un
pic d'activité exceptionnel
[Musique]